So we have this equation written in slope intercept form now, which is great.
But it's kind of yucky looking. At least, if you're me, and fractions aren't
necessarily your favorite thing. There is however, yet another form of a linear
equation that we can use to rewrite this, and maybe make it look a little bit
more pleasing. And that is called the general form of, of linear equation. We
can rate a general form of the general form proven to your equations as Ax plus
By equals C where A, B and C are all constants. In addition to this, we have one
more little requirement. One thing that's not allowed is for A and B to both be
equal to 0. If that was the case of course, this term would be 0. And this term
would be 0 as well. So we would just end up with the equation 0 plus 0 equals 0
which maybe true but isn't a linear equation because there are no variables in
it. What the general form does then, is basically shift everything on the
variable to one set of the equation and shift all the constant terms to the
other side of the equation and then of course combine whatever constant you have
into one number. So let's play around with this. Since the coefficient in form
of y doesn't have to be 1, it can be some other constant in general form. Let's
get rid of these fraction. What I'd like you to do then is to multiply both
sides of these equation by some number so that there are no more fractional
coefficients or constant terms. Try however, to make this number you multiply
both sides by the smallest number that you could use to get rid of the
fractions.